[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's poppin y'all welcome back to
another episode of bleacher reports
pre-game picks the only show in the
world where you
the people at home get to win free cash
prizes by simply predicting the random
[ __ ] that occurs
in the nba pregame as always we got a
lot of money to give to y'all we got a
lot of stuff
we got a lot of luca but before we get
to that let's get to these
pics baby
how crazy is that wait is that a three
let's see that's a three that's a three
step curry
wow my name i told y'all welcome to
pregame picks
let's get it
hey as always welcome to pregame picks i
am your host pierre akap with the plug
and i'm joined by my brother from
another
famous los los was popping it's been a
week brodie was popping
talk to me what's up i know you got
something we're back we're back we're
back
still hey stephanie 83 3's in april we
back
how you feeling how you feeling i feel
good hey
hey i'm i'm i'm doing i'm i'm doing how
i look
fine if you know what i'm saying whoa i
didn't say yeah
you know what i'm saying i apprecia i
appreciate the love you know what i'm
talking about
before we get into the too many people
and all of that today
we we starting off strong with your boy
we had a question that we started the
people off with
you know i got to start you off with it
where does steph
rank for the 2021
nvp and why i need to hear from the
steph fanatic you
everybody at home y'all let me know what
y'all thinking too i will get to y'all
in a minute but you know when it comes
to steph
lowe's got to go first talk to me
my only thing is if we make the playoffs
yes we can get mvp but if we don't make
the playoffs we can't get it
even though he is the best player in the
world with two legs
hey this this one this by me and you
like this
because that's the exact inside girl i
thought you i thought you may
was gonna be a little biased but listen
steph is
everybody right
never he the hottest i love that you
never buy us but you're right
if steph ain't making the playoffs i
ain't with it bro i'm not with it you
cannot
beat he just has an mvp he
yeah he just was he just was killing he
just was cut he just was killing
everybody all year
he ain't mvp that's just killing
everybody all year you know what
this that's also what i'm asking what
about the plan
are you counting the play in as the
playoffs
or does he have to be with jimmy lee in
one of the top seven seats
oh if we get in there we in there i
don't discriminate
i don't discriminate they gotta see us
if we in there we getting there i don't
discriminate we getting there
hey i don't make the rules hey it's
shout out to my boy kp kp out there
getting this woman
i don't think kb playing tonight uh i
think you're gonna be sitting this one
out but
yeah so if
shout out to kp but if steph ain't if
steph ain't it who is joey pediant
i don't think we had this conversation
yet
it was hard and hard and hard and
something happened
to heart and he played in a minute i
don't know what to say no more now
so who who is it is it
joel i think it got he gonna miss time
too i think it gotta be yokos joker's
the only one that ain't really missing
nb miss time lebron this time yeah joe
team suck yeah jojo so
who's the yoke i
i that's the warriors the warriors my
steph the warriors sucks
oh i'm tripping i'm tripping i'm
tripping i'm tripping
i'm tripping yeah yeah jokers yeah
jokers but but
but i was with donovan i'm with donovan
i'm with donny bravo
[Music]
i don't i don't give a damn if donovan
mitchell and then was number zero
donovan mitchell at the vp of the league
brody you know you my boy i rock with
you
uh a hundred grand 100 grand hey hey
hey who would have thought the jazz
would be number one
for the whole for for most of the entire
season
but
we can't ignore them because they're not
popular
we're not ignoring them because they're
not popular we're newer now because we
i don't want to disrespect donovan
because i like donovan but i don't
believe in the jazz but i do want to
give a shout out i'm in the comments
right now
to be smooth 11. he says steph
will finish second and b has been a
force all season
if curry wants mvp he'll need to keep
the pace up these remaining games
and that's exactly what me and lo saying
so be smooth 11
we going to give you 200 for the best
comment because you sound like me and
lois
for the rest of the season and the
warriors get into the playoffs
i think it's steph hands down i don't
give a damn what cd is yeah that's the
one thing i don't like about the mvp
award
forget rewarding the top seed steph
curry is the most valuable player right
now
and if they get into the playoffs it
speaks for itself
so shout out to my boy yes you know i'm
not
i'm not ignoring i'm not ignoring
donovan mitchell though because they're
no
their number they've been i'm not i'm
not i'm not ignoring donovan mitchell
either
but is he having a true mvp season bro
or is or is he just on a really good
team he's leading
i don't know but he's leading the best
team in the in the league so
it's like so it's like you know we're
saying we're saying oh he's just on a
good team look who he's winning with
he agrees winning we gonna resume this
conversation
but i do got to start out the first
prompt of the night for the people
that's trying to win some more money
who will make more shots in 10 minutes
steph
or luca los give the people some words
of encouragement which way should they
go
to win this money you ride them on luca
are you riding with steph hey
don't ever bet against steph
that's all you got to say against steph
yeah don't have a bet against steph
that's all i need to say what you mean
hey check it out about shoebag and stuff
right
i'ma bet against steph right now you
know why i'm a better guy steph i'm
gonna break it down for you
play by play i'm gonna make it simple
because this one i better get started
because i said cause i said still
no no i'm betting against steph
cause it ain't the real game this is
just warm-ups you got to remember that
steph don't take warm-up serious last
week or the couple weeks ago when we had
steph
his ass left early luca gonna be locked
in he gonna be focused he know we
watching
i talked to luca earlier today on the
selly if you know what i'm talking about
steph's gonna fade still when the last
time
you see luca warm up luke will be
playing too
he'd be joking when we was when we was
doing pre-game production
i was seeing luca warm-up serious no
smiles on his face
you was gone so you ain't see that but i
saw it he's still about to
and me and you're gonna make him better
and make sure y'all
y'all let us know which way y'all rock
it in the comments let's make a bet
i got luca when you got steph i got
steph
if i win i don't i don't want jumping
jacks
i won't i want jumping jacks but not the
normal jumper jacks we do i want
something called
jumping jacks on command which means you
do jumping jacks whenever i tell you to
you do you do how many i tell you
whenever
up to 50. yeah i bet i'm the same way if
you win
hey production is is the warriors out
there yet we ain't gonna start the clock
today both out there okay
hold on no great i'm getting worried
i'm getting worried that we not starting
the clock until both are out there
we're going to do 10 minutes and these
are shots
are we including layups as a layup a
shot hey
okay yeah okay we not start we're not
starting we're not starting until
until step take a shot man luca already
shooting like
steph could be walking out and luke
could be done taking two shots
hey but that's what i'm saying your boy
stephanie
hell take it serious andy gonna tell him
don't burn yourself out steph cause you
got to do it for 48 minutes
endurance endurance he got great
endurance and
and coach kurt and kirk gonna sit on 20
minutes
he gonna sit on the whole fourth of the
whole second
who the number let me ask you this since
you liked the jazz so much and we was
talking about
donovan mitchell mvp all that yeah so
hypothetically speaking if the warriors
was able to get in that play-in and
let's just say they got the ac
do you think the jazz are blowing
through the warriors or do you think the
warriors could upset them if
if steph is playing at this level in the
playoffs do you think that they could
upset the jazz in the first round
i never bet against steph i just told
you that boy
so hi so hi so
so how are you that high on the jazz
then if the warriors can beat the jazz
in the series
because because their their record is
proven their record is proven
we're talking about regular seasons look
at my homie
look at that little homie on this tick
tock [ __ ] hey he listening to that loss
[Applause]
love the kids i love the kids i love the
kids i love the kids feet
i love the kids hey
listen listen i love the kids too but
you know what this
these kids generation is missing the
real and you just told them surreal talk
that boy got
he needs some rhythm
look at him look at him what the f what
what is that
the tint top hey okay okay
hey look hey hey
hey
[Applause]
big homie that mean that means stefan
i'm coming he got out the way pretty
fast so i think that means
that i mean on warrior boys coming in
focus
focus eyes at the top
locked in no smiles no luca is a bucket
boy
luca is a bucket boy jesus christ
look at that no no snap yeah there you
go there they go
there here we go baby we never went out
first i see you steph
i see you still right now first who did
right now
shout out to my boy uh juan
juan toscano shout out to him 35
stitches
i saw you i saw you online i'm talking
about steph haircut too there we go
first shot we started hey lovely hey
look that's why i stopped talking that's
what i was looking at right now
okay luka get your ass back over there
i think you're just here he goes fresh
oh here he i told you
he's not didn't i tell you he'd be
playing i told you
hey i'm sorry y'all i didn't mean to
interrupt
whenever we can get a live bing [ __ ]
from los i need to shut up that's my
fault
that's my fault i just knew that's my
fault about to happen i just knew it was
about to happen i couldn't no
no no hey when you do the big beat it's
your world i'm just living in it
don't let me don't let me mess up your
rhythm again
why is luke everybody at home get it
twisted
is he gonna make it oh [ __ ] hey
let us know in the comments who y'all
got who gonna make the most shots in the
first 10 minutes
of warm-ups steph aluca i'm riding with
luca
lopes of course is riding with steph
steph is up one or nothing
uh the winner we got some cash prizes to
give to
you that's truthful stuff i need luca to
start making some layups
luca got to start making that might go
for 40 tonight
steph might go for 40 today
did you uh did you find out who his
barber was
oh my god yes sir good [ __ ] damn great
great person
great production that's a great person
yeah i found out that they don't count
production
great perspective take that back pretty
much nice if he tr
and he's traveling we not if we if he
if he's traveling we're not counting he
got to do a real basketball move
you said travel yeah don't get the room
up [ __ ] that's the one
[ __ ] you don't know about no doubt hey
put the camera back on luca what the
hell is dorian finney smith doing behind
luca
i
that's so funny
tell where you been at bro
that's so fire i don't know guys did not
know that luca they hit one shot luka
doodle ain't he
shout out to my boy d.h
said lucas luca and steph fools around
too much
we got justin he says luca making 13
before steph gets to 10.
i like that rocking with your boy no
know somebody um steph step from the
tunnel uh oh a little bit big from stuff
i look i love being banked
and he missed he usually don't miss her
oh he usually don't miss him right there
[Applause]
so he really went to the free throw line
he went to the free throw line yes sir
get get that money back and he missed
and he they got one blitz split took
that watching though
watching them how many straight up and
down
split cat how many three steph made this
month
83 boy 83 how many didn't keep making
tonight
listen how many making it high school i
made like uh
10 10
because i was gonna say i was gonna say
nine but just like spades you never bid
nine
oh you've been here i don't think you've
never been i don't think he's doing
he's not doing 10 on the head brody
nobody's checking him though
nobody's i think he's going to be 10 on
the 10th straight no nobody's checking
him on
no i'm checking him no i feel you i'm
saying he might make more
but 10 on the head is it's two on the
head he's going to do like 11 or 12.
no and we got a top ball game shout out
to look
shout out to steph doing uh doing all
them love dumb little pointless sad
stretches luca go ahead take the lead
come on luca lucas come on now and look
at steel okay
lucas here can't shoot cut it out okay
what is what is step stretcher right now
please tell me what steph is stretching
are you talking about this
you don't know [ __ ] about basketball i
don't even know how i'm on this show
with you
uh right now i don't know why you're
stretching but this is what we do
this is what we do since you know
since you since you know so much what is
it working on you don't do some [ __ ]
just to be doing it
i don't stretch but all you know and two
for all you know he's stretching his ass
cheek what do you need his ass to
stretch forward
so we can't step through it we all gonna
be doing it hey and i got steph missing
jump shots
i got lost walking off the set um it's
all a mind game ladies and gentlemen
luca gonna take this home he take it off
the warm-up my boy ready to get hot he
got the kobe r being on
we up two and if you pick luca with me
you're gonna get some money
that's another one 11-8 stop playing
with me man i does this
hey man we need some big things in the
comments man who got the [ __ ] out there
y'all
watch y'all
over the next five years who would you
build around steph
or luca and i want a smart hand the
dumbest question you could
ever ask me in your life that's the
dumbest question you could ever ask me
in your life
i only asked it because they asked me to
i only asked it because they asked you i
already knew your hands yeah don't you
ever don't you don't
don't listen don't ask don't do what
everybody say don't do that cause that's
hey look look oh my god why steph though
oh my goodness
that's a good point steffi is thirty
nine stephanie is thirty three
and five that's definitely thirty i
think i was thinking about that too but
steph is a shooter
shooting a ball handler he's not a
dunker he's not gonna lose athleticism
he he gonna just be running around
shooting bruh and he can
he can go for big big to be a ray allen
and just move him without the ball
steph is scary bro luca what are you
doing
luca luca what are you doing i don't
look at jordan
jordan pool ain't never saw a shaheen
like
[Music]
hey steph getting in his bag now i love
you
whoever said that 13 and 10 and 10 [ __ ]
you know slap yourself snap yourself
look at this listen
and pull up rock and roll while we get
to the last
the last few minutes of this round i
don't know what luke are doing
but before he pissed me off i'ma just
jump this to the subject i told you
don't bet against them
don't bet hey we got a shout out you
know we got a shout out
we got a shout out dame dang dang dang
quartered the tweet
from bleach report about this show a
couple weeks ago oh yeah shout out to
somebody oh yeah that's family yes sir
that's family right
yeah that's fantastic yes sir
shout out to the game really put us on
the map
game time shout out damn hey so this
week
we need steph steph where you at quote
us
come on steph hey we need you hey steph
if you called us i need ten dollars
hey you know this and that's just love
because we found
it because ain't nothing for you give
step hey for that for the next 30
seconds
give steph uh uh a reason of why he need
to
show us some love go ahead give him
stuff we're doing this
steps that step no stuff no cause it's
love it's family it's north carolina man
north carolina hold north carolina down
that's why
you fear me mvp we on the show chain mvp
when we say stephen curry
oh
i'm
we down to the last minute i don't know
what luke is doing but if luca don't
catch up i am never going to bet on luca
again
come on
don't bet against steph come on look at
what the hell is you doing that [ __ ]
ass jump shot
there you go make up your bet on luke
did he make it
hey doo-doo oh my gosh bro
i'm about to i'm about to walk off the
set in a minute i'm about to walk out
this is hell
no he is you know he is hey hey look hey
look since we're right here in this
begin ad
and steph about to win even though he's
doing some talking to his twin or
whatever
that means all right this ain't over
this ain't over this ain't over hold
your
horses we got 40 seconds hey
since we're here i want to apologize to
luca live
before he even got to the league i said
luca won't gonna be like that luca
luca nice his hair come on lucas nice to
see you
come on in the lead look at luke with
all these trick shots
i told you hey steph what are you doing
with a lad hey last shot of warm-ups for
the warriors is it going to be a make or
miss
call it now we got we got 15 seconds
left i make or miss
it's gonna
come on come on hurry up shoot the
[ __ ] ball shoot
okay okay okay okay hey okay this
is oh come on luca oh my god come on man
don't better get stuff i told you that
boy
you don't bet your money getting stuff
boys the quickest way
that's that's that's the extra two
minutes up there
we still going what the hell what hey
what the hell is going on man i feel
like i'm getting cheated now
uh no [ __ ]
i'm i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] down
porsche oh my god the last shot of
warm-ups
hey hey go through that look
uh huh y'all don't know y'all don't even
want us y'all don't want to see that
with that bing bing
bing boo baby lay you with y'all
you didn't like that that's move right
there yeah no i did not like that i did
not like that
yeah they they counted real hooper stuff
that's real uber stuff that is not come
on come on now
that's real hoopa [ __ ] my ass shout out
to these five people that's gonna be
taking 500 dollars home
they rocked with my boy loss so red mom
the 41 is going to take 500 home
jesse is going to take 500 zebo uh wrong
one and then canolo 5. so shout out to
those guys
and uh those females are taking five
hundred dollars home i'm
upset that's why i don't have as much
energy 100
giving love to the winners because i
feel like
lucas cheated me and my people
no no no no don't bet your money against
still
they just won 500 p
bro that's what i'm saying you know how
stupid you got to be he'll not be
watching and tuning into this [ __ ]
every week 500. i thought it was about
to be 200.
i thought it might be 200 it's 500
dollars we gave we gave we gave 200 to
do
earlier just for a comment cause we like
this comment
yo yo 200 cause you commented so
just give it away god just just giving
away money just giving away my and you
know what
to wrap up the show we gonna give away
another 200
after i don't know what the hell
draymond green is doing he need to not
do that [ __ ] again because i like
draymond
homie right there got the titties do rag
on
he bogus as hell uh final shot of the
warriors warm up
make a miss for 200 let us know what
y'all think in the comments i think lo
said it's going to be a make
i'm going to go with uh
nobody gonna get me it's going to be a
make no
it's always a mate it's always me
hey hey when it hits zero y'all is over
watch closely
watch closely watch closely let's see it
was on steph
it was old steph at the buzzer it was on
steph and the buzzer
split cac at the bottom
[Laughter]
i need a replay
split guy from step at the buzzer and he
ran out watch replay right here
look look look split cash oh and a
buzzer
and when i was a mate that was a mick
that was amazing split give it away
look he out we out we out
we out we out yes sir
look stop can i get a word from
production watch it
watch that split cat watch this follow
through too look um
i'm trying to get word both of them
right there are we counting that
what do you mean that's the mess
pause it pause it pause it on zero
please pause it on zero please pause it
those zeros start hitting it
right now right there
wow
they said big fella but that's the stuff
i know but
it's about it's about the clock okay
okay yes
that's the last shot and he banked he
doink the doing throwing
it's over what they say about they say
he did a double joint
like the bears kicker from a couple
years ago
he
[Applause]
oh my god y'all they they wanted me to
lose today oh i'm sick
i'm sick
[Music]
hey shout out to the people that didn't
get fouled
hey y'all i just dropped the song go
[Music]
support my boy hey los you got the
mavericks or the warriors
i i got the mavs hey i got the main
fight to go forward
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you